have you ever bought a ticket to see
another comedy that you weren't in it's
been a little bit yeah yeah but of
course I have I just can't think of one
yeah but of course I have
there's something about Mary is the last
one I saw come on there's got to be
another Wow I thought kingpins before
that true because Best in Show came out
after that I said that our DVD oh no
we're talking about in the theater in
the theater like buying a ticket I
thought that you because being in
comedies like Dog Days which is in
theaters right now is can I ask this
about you yeah when you see a comedy and
any friend of yours is in it do you just
quietly go it's it's even it's not even
that it's a man I claim I'm much funnier
waiter I also go into myself uh-huh
so when I'm watching you know laughs Oh
Jo Jo's in it in my head and it'll be
like yeah you didn't read for that you
know of course this is exactly yeah yeah
you have my dition you didn't hate for
it
yeah and cuz you were like doing some
[ __ ] yeah and this is you you you
you [ __ ] your home life your own life
up okay so there is a movie that my
friend John Hamburg made called
why him
yeah and there was a character in it
called Gustav de manservant yeah and I
was like I'm like oh my god and he's
like so Tom I was kind of thinking about
you when I read the movie and he's like
I would love you to come in just you
know it gets political just come in and
read for Gustav the manservant and I'm
like akhiya I just some of it in German
yeah and I'm frolicking around and I've
got like a like the exact right like
weird tank top shirt on yeah felt like I
nailed it we're wrestling him on the
ground is that amazing yeah I don't hear
anything for a No
yeah and then oh he sends me an email
cause we're pals like oh we're going a
different way and I'm like oh we're
going a different way with the role that
I was kind of in your head yeah and then
I see the trailer of the movie and it's
like one of my probably my favorite
living actor it's keegan-michael key Wow
but like so then you just go down a
rabbit holes this way to see comedies
yeah so just like well that's great
casting son of a [ __ ] and he's got
funny mountain jobs
do you ever have bad auditions I feel
like you don't know I've tanked some
stuff for sure and how you can I have I
mean I I know I've talked about a lot on
this podcast but yeah and I wanted to
you know talk to him about because I
have PTSD from some of them sure like
they're so terrible yeah that I why I
had one front of Amy Poehler ones oh
where I think moms so bad that I hit my
head over a water ball when I was
walking to my car
and I bled for my head oh my god like I
abused myself I got one for him this is
a weird deep cut but it was during Parks
and Rec they sometimes will bring in
other actors just to fail so that they
can show the studio that they're
positive about it and I'm pretty sure I
read for Nick Offerman's role a riot but
like most of the people in charge of the
show didn't even come it was just like a
like we hands to the slaughter did you
know that going in or not I did not know
that going in I was just like oh they
wrote this very specifically for someone
else you're not that person you are not
getting it Wow but everyone's well I had
a friend who had a sitcom and I'll just
said I'm not gonna see the person yeah
but what the sitcom is yes but this
person has to come in everyone read for
it and eventually I started seeing out
loud I can't [ __ ] read for that I
mean no this person is my friend yeah
and then I know they casted the part
right but I get called in for it anyway
I know yeah I'm in a room with no
producer just a intern with a camera
yeah yeah and I just I've literally what
did I show up I already know what it is
yeah like do you need another one no do
I could do another yeah no it's great
yeah did you even get it yeah it was
great and that was like heart [ __ ]
breaking yeah but you know what I've
heard I once heard them closing Will
Arnett's deal through the door I was
like oh my god tell well we will do
anything anything yeah as long as he
does it yeah great
yes it's role of Gary it's 18 days in
Vancouver yeah it's the stuff favorite
Nations yeah I just don't see anybody oh
hi Tom break a leg with the terminology
like if you have a good nation or your
favourite nations or they put a pin
actually still put a pin in I don't know
that means what put a pin in you what
does that mean
yeah no they put a pin in you means we
want someone else what if that falls
through you're in the next office ah
either the backup or like the second
backup I've been pinned so many time off
getting pinned I right right so somebody
made that up mm-hmm by the way they also
here's here's one for you they're just
checking your avails this stance will be
like hey checking your valves for August
you know 26 27 28 oh yeah I'm available
okay anyway remember when like yeah
remember when that cool thing was called
I'm still available was that like wha
yeah oh no no no no that's not yeah I'm
afraid to call so when they go check the
veil
they put a pin in you Brian yeah and
then you and then it's getting closer to
August 28th where that you know you
cleared it yeah and do you go do I call
and go anyone's up and like you're just
gonna get a call sheet tomorrow yeah
yeah do I just I wake up and I go there
yeah I just wait for the 28th and I'm
just not in Vancouver not only can I not
go see comedies cuz it's always a tiny
bit sad yeah cuz like you all you're
gonna be reminded is yeah Rob Huebel is
a genius all right
yeah Nick Kroll can do almost anything
why [ __ ] it
yeah that's how I fell about you on Sean
save the world I literally sat there and
watched you were hers thank you and I
said to myself yeah I should get out mmm
cuz whatever he just did I can't do that
mmm I mean you were just it was a
rehearsal you know you had all the lines
memorized I didn't have very many lines
that's another secret and then you were
like going in and out of this like
little secret be a side dish like I am
in dog days I'm nine minimum keep doing
keep doing it yes so that the side dish
is a secret oh when you're a side dish
yeah you're aware of kimchi right I love
it yeah yeah of course I'm aware of it
yeah yeah my Korean friends sometimes
you have two fridges one for kimchi do
you have Korean friends yes I do
three what are their names John Cho oh
he is a friend yes Bobby Lee yeah and
Cathy shim I know Cathy - nothing's
married to my writing partner tell Cathy
I said hi you don't have to you have a
podcast happy I got the only her right
now yeah hi Cathy I love Kathy
easy no she's no she's great I've looked
with the remarried to my right
[Music]